[Music]
there's a guy who went to sweet here of
course that's where are they of course
[Applause]
where are they the two handsomest people
in the world who's this guy really I
just mentioned I'm sure and then I just
heard a voice in the audience they asked
some Swedes here what's happened to this
country we're so intolerant welcome to
our fine land I don't represent
everybody so do not judge America too
harshly I'm a God in Finland though did
you know that you're not crazy about the
Finns though huh okay that went sour
we'll just leave that alone
big scandal in China you want to hear
about this it's all I got so here we go
did you know this Chinese authorities
recently arrested over 900 people for
selling counterfeit meat counterfeit
meat yeah China warned the u.s. that the
meats being sold under its street name
Arby's
[Applause]
[Music]
my daughter loves it JCPenney has these
new ads out have you seen these Andy
they're really weird basic anatomy yeah
they have these new ads that thank
customers for quote coming back to us
yeah then the customers explained we're
only coming back to return crap we
bought at JC Penney's that's really the
reason don't get excited
I don't know if you remember this
earlier this week it was announced that
Barbara Walters is stepping down yeah
and this is interesting footage just
surfaced from 1962 of a young Barbara
Walters working undercover as a Playboy
bunny that's true yeah you can tell it's
Barbara Walters because she keeps asking
men if they want their drinks on the
walks
that was terrible
Taco Bell's in the news some Taco Bell
restaurants are testing out new
breakfast tacos
breakfast tacos yeah Taco Bell said
their breakfast tacos are perfect for
people who were starting their day
stoned
according to a new study that just came
out couples who have a sex schedule are
more likely to stay together if you have
a sex schedule yeah even better news my
wife penciled me in for late August
[Applause]
that's me getting ready yeah that's my
I'm getting ready to go move tweet the
tie and then jump towards the camera
right it's pretty hot in August though
you might want to wait a couple months
after according a new survey that just
came out 42% of Americans have an
unfavorable view of hipsters yeah yeah
yeah yeah when they heard this hipster
said big deal we had an unfavorable view
of ourselves way before was
[Applause]
[Music]
I love how you throw in an iPhone I
don't know everyone has a smartphone
that elitist device ladies and gentlemen
there's a new movie that's coming out
about Bill quiet there's a new movie
coming out about Bill and Hillary
Clinton's early years together yeah yeah
the movie has a happy ending and then
Hillary walks in
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I just brought two nations together
yeah yeah thanks things were getting
pretty sticky between us and the Swedes
yeah it was real dicey there now we
stand together all right